the more and more you read and the more
and more you Besta you it's a
neverending story with this West Coast
East Coast
top rappers have been shot and killed
Tupac is supposed to perform at the club
that night in a dark SS Impala pulls up
alongside shoots Biggie several times
and he dies on the way to the hospital
so now there's blood on the ground and
then an unexpected thing takes place
they had to resurrect the case and have
us take a new look at it and see if
we've missed anything you believe behind
all of this it's puffy he knew that Suge
Knight was trying to hunt him down he
turned to the streets and said can you
guys handle this for me and now they're
going to go and retaliate to hunt down
Tupac the Cadillac pulls up he leans out
and shoots and ultimately kills Tupac
Shakur why were you removed from the
case of 2009 is there a reason to want
to go really find out the truth I
believe the public should at least be
informed as to what took place in the
investigation what evidence we develop
and how this all fits together it's not
what you know it's what you can prove
[Music]
so today I have with me Greg Kading who
was the detective investigating the
homicide on Tupac as well as Biggie so
one day
Russell pulls investigation of 97
binders that are four inches of piece is
handed over to him to find out an
investigator Morin see what really
happened at Tupac and Biggie he was a
lead detective on that and recently a
documentary came out called murder rap
as well as a Netflix series 10 episodes
titled on solved I believe right unsub
which has become a big hit everybody's
talking about look I got a painting
behind me with many different characters
and one of them is Tupac I was a 1996
graduates I've always been curious about
Tupac I said why don't we get great
kidding out here so Greg thanks for
making the time I'm coming out and my
pleasure thank you for having me so
before getting this you had already done
200 cases give or take yeah throughout
my career I was already as you know a
senior detective at the time that I got
this case but I had come through
narcotics and homicide and had a really
deep background in gang investigation so
it just seemed like a natural fit to
take on this case now was this something
that you went after was it something
that was just given to you out of
nowhere it was given to me out of
nowhere really I was working major
narcotics and I got a phone call one day
from detective at Robbery Homicide
Division who was overseeing the new
resurrected Christopher Wallace biggie
smalls murder which was being reexamined
due to a lawsuit that was being waged
against the city of Los Angeles wherein
allegations had been made from the
Wallace estate that LAPD officers were
complicit in the murder complicit in the
murder and is that kind of what
attracted he to it or you already kind
of knew this was taking place I had some
knowledge of the case but very limited
really just a superficial knowledge of
the case I was attracted to it just by
the the challenge of it all I enjoyed
things that had to do with gangs I
enjoyed things that had to do with
narcotics and of course this is a
high-profile murder where in both of
those worlds were going to be visited so
all of those things
attracted me to it and and I knew the
department wanted to get to the bottom
of it before even getting into it what
is the itch why why do you want to be in
a detective like what is the inspiration
behind you know I want to go find out
more I want to dig up more where does
that come from have you always been like
that
yeah I've always enjoyed puzzles and
that's what homicide any investigation
is it's about you know finding pieces of
evidence and trying to fit them all
together to get a comprehensive picture
of something and so there's a challenge
involved and it's it's a lot of fun
being a detective and especially in a
city like Los Angeles it can be a lot of
fun it can be really challenging but
when you have a good partner and you got
to be the team around you it's all
worthwhile did you listen to hip-hop
back then or no will you hip-hop guy or
no I know I have to admit I was and I'm
kind of a classic rocket guy I came up
on you know Bob Seger and Aerosmith and
that type of stuff I feel different
music it's slightly different music and
you know in again back in the mid 90s of
course there was kind of an adversarial
relationship between law enforcement and
the gangster rap community you know
songs from mwa like if the police and
that were coming out and so you know
there was just these two different
worlds that work we're kind of frowning
upon each other
did you personally see them as the enemy
yourself was it kind of like I want to
put a stop to this and I'm willing to
contribute was that kind of your mindset
or I'm just gonna go do my job well the
gangs you know we perceived as being you
know their their detriment to their
community and so that's what it is
you're trying to protect the people in
those communities that are trying to
just get through their lives with
pursuing you know their their own
agendas and then these gangs they wreak
all kinds of havoc in the communities so
somebody has to be there to try to curb
that and that's us that's law
enforcement did you have a personal
incident that happened to you with a
gang member or anything that even create
a more fire in your belly or not really
you never had an issue yourself well
there were certainly gang members who I
despised you know guys that were out
there you know committing murders and
robbing houses and raping women and that
type of thing but with that being said I
developed really good relationships with
certain gang members
and we became friends and even guys that
I'd sent to prison for years I'd stay in
touch with and and once they got out and
it formed friendships with them so
everything really is taken on an
individual basis but you know you have
to judge the behavior at certain times
donors and I asked is because I can only
imagine if you put ninety seven
four-inch binders on this table I mean
there's a high likelihood one of them is
gonna fall off right to want to do that
and pursued you can obviously say no to
it right you can say no I don't want to
do this I'm gonna pass it to somebody
else do you have the ability to do that
or is it cating this is yours you got to
take you to go get the job done I could
have declined it okay no because they
did they wanted somebody who would be
interested and motivated to do the work
and so they didn't want to have somebody
that the work was forced on it just
doesn't it doesn't amount to a good
objective proactive approach so I liked
it because I I have a certain kind of
obsessive compulsive personality and if
you put something like that in front of
me you know the challenge is and I'm
gonna you know I'm gonna do my darndest
to figure it out so and you need the
right personality for this because
because this is like I was telling you
earlier you know so I'm like okay I'm
gonna sit with Gregg great we've done a
lot of different interviews on the
channel we've never gone into the
hip-hop side and you know my interest
with Tupac I said okay great let me let
me want to pursue this but the more and
more you read and the more and more you
investigated it's a neverending story
with this with the all the conspiracies
17 conspiracies that could be ride 5
over here here's a person on this side
it was this guy was that guy so when it
was first given to you what was your
first approach when you got it did you
say let me go through all this material
first then or did you say I don't want
to look at any of this stuff let me do
my own investigation and I'll come to it
no we had to review all the information
that was available at the time all of
those binders we had to go through with
a fine-tooth comb and start piecing
things together and develop the most
viable theories because there are there
were some you know there was just some
ridiculous allegations and theories out
there that you know we we had to listen
to but we couldn't really take seriously
just based on on face value but put
to gather all the information that
contained in those binders did lead us
to the most viable and practical of the
theories and decided that those would be
the ones that we'd spend our time and
energy trying to prove or disprove got
it so so you're you're getting it you're
looking at you're reading all the
material yourself Russell Poole himself
had come up to a conclusion right and he
was going in a direction where he felt
it was you know who he thought had
handled the business for biggie or Tupac
first of all what was that to the
audience assuming they know nothing and
I'm not seeing the documentary or read
your book and secondly what direction
did you go after you
read that so Russell Poole he developed
a loose theory based on some strong
circumstantial evidence that there were
some police officers moonlighting for
Death Row Records and some LAPD officers
that may or may not be associated with
Suge Knight and through kind of a series
of random circumstances put together
this theory that these cops were
involved in the cops that he ultimately
identified was a notoriously bad cop
from the LAPD a disgraced cop named
David Mack who after the murders of
Biggie Smalls
had robbed a bank and you know there was
some indication that he was associated
or with with gangs down in Compton so
all of these things led Russell Poole
down this road where he started to fit
information together to serve that
theories purpose and we took it as a
serious Theory there was as I said
really good circumstantial information
to believe that this could be true and
so we pursued that as a viable option
while keeping in mind that it may not be
true also
and so it's kind of through a process of
elimination that we'd take a theory if
we could disprove it then we knew we
could set it aside and move on to the
next theory got it great do you mind if
we go to the other room on the board I
have pictures of everybody and I kind of
want you to walk us through the
connection of everybody with each other
where you know when you're investigating
I would picture like you know some of
these
movies that they're doing investigation
they got all the characters up and you
kind of trying to figure out how you got
to the bottom of who killed oh yeah
let's go to the other oh yeah
so Greg I want to take a different angle
with this because I think this gives the
audience a better visual to kind of see
how everybody's connected to each other
so if you can kind of walk us through
what we know here is obviously it
started with biggie
investigation Tupac kind of came in and
then I have eazy-e here I have P Diddy
and Suge Knight and a lot of different
characters even Johnnie Cochran at
Russell pool if you can kind of walk us
through some of the connections here
that'll probably be most helpful
great yeah and this is very helpful for
me also during the investigation this is
exactly what we did put together a big
flow chart so we could put faces to
names and start making connections so
this is this is the way to present the
case so I appreciate that of course
you've got Biggie and Tupac there are
victims killed in 1996 killed in 1997
over here you have Russell Poole who was
the primary investigation back in 1997
assigned to investigate Biggie's murder
and so of course we know that biggie was
with P Diddy at Bad Boy Records in to
pocket the time in 96 was under the
death row death row with Suge Knight at
the helm so these are all just sites
some of the ancillary characters these
guys aren't really related insofar as
the murder investigation is concerned
but of course we know ez and Snoop Dogg
and dr. Dre from the founding days of
death row you know easy coming out of
NWA and Dre and then of course Snoop
Dogg joins forces and they all become
how much do you buy into the conspiracy
about the AIDS where Suge Knight said
what he said on Jimmy Kimmel or you
don't you don't that's you've never
investigated to find out the validity of
it anyways we didn't take a deep dive
into it I don't believe it I don't
believe that he you know injected him
with a needle full of even though he
said it on Kimmel right well Suge Knight
said a lot of things sure most of which
are untrue so it's just his nature to
throw out you know all kinds of nonsense
you know he said Tupac's alive he said
that did he killed him he said you know
he said a million different he'd make a
good politician today there you go
perhaps when he gets out of prison
become one so walk us through the rest
okay so you know back in 96 Tupac
Shakur's we know was in Las Vegas Nevada
watching a Mike Tyson fight
he's along with Suge Knight in this big
entourage of people with Death Row
Records there at the MGM after the fight
Tupac gets into our fist fight with a
gang member from Compton named Orlando
Anderson his street name was baby lane
after this this fight takes place
security gets there they break it up
everybody goes their own way and Tupac
Shakur later on that evening or on the
way over to shug's nightclub
do you mind highlighting this I don't
mean to interrupt you
Orlando they got into a fight because of
Trayvon claimed that he took the death
row
medallion and at that time he was given
$10,000 for every medallion that they
took apparently it was the case right or
all of that's true except the thing
about him offering up any kind of bounty
for those medallions has always just
been kind of Street rumor legend it's
never been validated or verified but
there was a rumor on the street that
there was an offer of $10,000 to get one
of these death row medallions which
Tupac had and many of the other people
at death row possessed so they're
heading over to Suge Knight's Club this
is after the Tyson fight Suge Knight is
got this club in Las Vegas called the
662 it's a new enterprise for him he's
trying to secure a gambling license and
a liquor license so it's a really big
night it's an important night he's got
Tupac alongside of him in a BMW
Tupac's supposed to perform at the at
the club that night and Mike Tyson's
supposed to make an appearance so it's a
big deal while there in route there a
white Cadillac pulls up alongside of
them somebody leans out of the back
window and opens fire hits Tupac
multiple times and he ultimately dies
six days later in the hospital so the
murder investigation out in Las Vegas
begins immediately and they begin to
question people including Reggie Wright
who was the head of security at death
row they
try to question sug he's not cooperative
many other people within that entourage
get questioned but the cops don't really
make any real headway because people
aren't cooperating so as a result of
that fight that took place between Tupac
and baby lane Suge Knight gets himself
involved in that melee and gets sent
back to prison on a probation violation
so six months later when biggie is shot
Suge Knight is in prison arms and he's
in the LA County Jail facing these
probation violations biggie comes back
to LA in 1997 he's with Diddy and his
cousin little cease and the rest of the
bad-boy entourage they attend a party at
the Petersen Auto Museum on March 7th of
1997 and as they're leaving the fire
marshals close to the party down for
overcrowding as they're leaving Diddy
and his bodyguard there in a suburban
leaving the location following them is
biggie smalls his cousin and several
other members of the entourage and a
dark SS Impala pulls up alongside very
similar to what had taken place in Vegas
six months earlier an assailant reaches
out the window
shoots biggie several times and he dies
on the way to the hospital so now the
1997 biggie smalls investigation is
unfolding and it's assigned to this guy
Russell Poole who is an LAPD robbery
homicide detective got it and and a part
of this when the shooting happened here
and he went to jail
didn't he make an offer to him for
$16,000 to say that he wasn't hitting
him he was trying to help him did that
actually take place it did there is some
question as whether it was $16,000 or
$60,000 we've gotten different versions
of that story but we know he did go to
testify in his hearing and favorably
trying to say yeah should was not
kicking me he was actually trying to
stop the fight and he shouldn't be you
know violated for his probation the
judge doesn't buy it he's can see that
Orlando's lying through his teeth and
Suga ultimately gets sent back to prison
so it didn't help at all didn't help at
all
all it did was expose him as
as a perjurer got it okay let's so from
here at this point we have both west
coast east coast top rappers have been
shot and killed have been shot and
killed he died six days later he died
you know on the way to the hospital
there's a recording apparently on you
can hear the recording on the driver so
I'm trying to find a hospital what do I
find the hospital and then he dies on
the way there right so what happens next
so after he's DOA the murder
investigation begins to unfold they
secure the crime scene back at the
Petersen Auto Museum and as I said
shortly thereafter Russell Poole becomes
one of the primary investigators until
to to look into the matter and he begins
to figure out that there has been this
ongoing rivalry between these two camps
it's been going on for years there's
already been violence between the two
camps and we're seeing that there's this
hostile animosity going on not only
between Biggie and Tupac
but between Diddy and Suge Knight and
then their respective crews there was
like these different levels of the
conflict that are going on so he begins
to develop the you know a theory that
all of this is probably due to some type
of interaction among all of these these
people and then an unexpected thing
takes place while he's investigating
that he hears and responds to a shooting
that takes place between two LAPD
officers this guy Frank LIGO who was
working undercover narcotics at the time
in an off-duty officer named Kevin gains
these two guys get into a road rage
incident they both pull guns on each
other Frank like shoots and kills Kevin
Gaines and during the investigation of
that shooting he finds out that Kevin
Gaines is driving a vehicle that's
registered to Suge Knight's wife and
during the follow up of that
investigation finds out that Sheree the
night his wife was actually dating this
guy and had been for some time an LAPD
officer so for him it raises the
question why is an LAPD officer dating
the wife of a known criminal and a guy
who's got a reputation in lost
that precedes him for violence in that
type of thing now this time does he know
that that's taking place or no it's not
public info sug is aware of the fact
that this incident takes place he's
aware of the fact that they've
determined that his wife has loaned her
vehicle to this police officer he know
what read the event or he learned
afterwards he knew it before he was
aware they was what oh yeah so they were
kind of separated separated on the outs
yeah so Johnny Cochran ultimately
defends the lawsuit that's lodged
against the police department
representing Kevin Gaines it doesn't
really go anywhere but you know Johnnie
Cochran is of course a infamous LA
lawyer oh yeah oh yeah so during during
by the way his credibility does he have
a strong credibility of who he was with
his past
at the time you know Russell Poole was
known as a really diligent hard-working
respected detective how he worked on
something this big before a case this
level just some ancillary involvement
and when Cosby's kid was killed in Los
Angeles he'd worked hundreds of gang
homicides and gang investigations what
he's doing he knew it he's doing it and
I remember when this when this took
place both of these events took place P
Diddy puffy and Snoop got on and they
interviewed and they said we got to
bring it together and it was a way of
them trying to bring peace let's bring
west coast East Coast together you could
tell there was fear in both of them
because if this continues he's probably
next there's a lot of other people that
are going to be next they're trying to
bring peace yeah well particularly snip
dog you know I think he was in the
middle of it Dre didn't really want
anything to do with all the violence
nonsense going on around death row one
would rate he just wanted to produce and
do his thing and make make great music
so he wasn't about all this drama that
was going on
Snoop also he just wanted to you know he
wanted to do the same thing for all
intent purposes make music he wanted to
be able to go to New York and you know
do things out in New York and promote
his music out there but this conflict
going on between them was making all of
that very difficult did you watch that
one that interview took place when they
were trying to bring peace
like do you do you when you're
investigating do you look at those types
of things or not at all well of course
you know hey we're really not trying to
hurt anybody nothing really happened or
does that actually bring more attention
to say why is he getting on there saying
something like this now does it put more
of a target on him for saying that or no
personally I think he would have
preferred there be a truce of peace
pre-pre both of these events or post
prior okay and after both because I
think he wasn't he knew how dangerous
this was over here you know he's a New
Yorker he's not a gangster by nature
he's just a guy who wants to make music
and and be an entrepreneur and and you
know not have to deal with all of the
crap that was going on around Suge
Knight when it got really bad was when
they were in Atlanta and then both of
these guys in their entourage were at a
nightclub and they got into a little
squabble over some girls on the dance
floor and you know one thing led to a
pushy match and then of course security
tells him to all to go outside and then
his bodyguard pulls a gun and shoots and
kills his bodyguard so now there's blood
on the ground he holds him responsible
for the death of his friend and the
conflict isn't really bad this all takes
place long before these guys get killed
how much love for so that's shooting in
ninety that was in 95
so in Atlanta so year before so a year
before this and of course even before
that 94 he gets assaulted at the quad
Studios in New York and believes that
both puffy and Diddy at least for a
little while initially he thought that
puffy and Diddy had set him up and they
were responsible for that do you that
robbery I don't think so whatsoever and
I think he came to learn that it wasn't
all these guys in here amongst these
guys is it fair to say that these three
were not gangsters he was the only one
correct definitely not these guys you
know he was a drug dealer just a street
corner guy you know of course Diddy was
coming up in the music business and kept
his nose clean for all intent purposes
should was definitely from the
neighborhood he wanted that whole gang
atmosphere in reputation to be what
death row was and Tupac in
kind of become any an affiliate of the
gang that Suge Knight represented which
was the mob Pyro's he was not a gang
member any way shape or form but he
certainly was associating with them in
claiming them because he was looking for
protection not only protection but a
sense of you know for lack of
brotherhood and gotten along is just
most of them don't right motion airs if
you get into a game you're missing
something there's not a father figure
there's not a French brother you have so
you kind of want to get into something
but but based on what I read is Tupac
had a lot of different personalities one
thing is the entertainer one day we're
taking over the world one day it's a
philosopher one day it's the gangster so
you didn't know who really showed up so
you know even him not necessarily taking
claims of one certain city whether it's
Baltimore New York LA what are you
really representing right yeah but he
was man of the people
yet not really affiliated 20 gang so
background wise would you say he wasn't
like an O GOG gangster compared to him
oh no no none whatsoever
you know he was a complicated guy but
you know he certainly wasn't you know
okay a gang member
okay we call him an affiliate just by
this you know just by nature of the fact
that he is affiliating or you don't call
him a gangster got it not at all but we
do have to remember that he was at odds
with these guys when he was in jail
should was the one that came out there
and rescued him got the bail money uh
brought him to Los Angeles allowed him
to make some you know phenomenal music
and so he saw in Suge a big brother or
possibly father figure or mentor and
then of course Suge Knight's entourage
embraced Tupac and he saw with them a
sense of belonging got it okay so what
happens next so what happens next after
this happens of Russell Poole then
becomes after the shooting in this hole
at the aftermath of this cop on cop
shooting another incident takes place in
Los Angeles were a corrupt cop a rogue
cop named David Mack robs a bank in Los
Angeles the bank of America and runs
away runs out of there with like sub
$22,000 investigators quickly figure out
who he what his involvement was and they
arrest him and when they arrest him they
find out that he drives a black 1996
Chevy Impala which is the exact same
vehicle as the suspects used in the
murder of Biggie they also find that
there's photographs of him wearing all
of the a red suit and a red brim hat
what was very indicative of how Suge
Knight dressed and he's from Compton and
he's got a loose affiliation with some
Bloods according to some of the letters
he's written while he's in jail he's
claiming these Westside riders I believe
it was a Compton Street gang so Russ
Poole knows that he has at least one cop
who's loosely affiliated with Suge
Knight through his wife and now he's got
another cop who's claiming to be a gang
dressing in red clothes indicative of
the Bloods and drives a black Impala
which is matches the suspect vehicle in
Biggie's shooting so he begins to form a
theory that potentially this guy was
involved in the murder of Biggie Smalls
adding to that we discovered that while
he was in jail for the bank robbery he's
visited by this guy named Amir Muhammad
and he goes into the jail and visits
David Mack
he becomes aware of this visit and he
finds out that during the investigation
into Biggie's murder an informant had
mentioned the name Amir as being the
shooter of Biggie Smalls
and so he finds out there's an Amir that
visits David Mack and that kind of adds
fuel to the fire of the theory that he's
trying to develop purely a theory purely
theory good circumstantial support or
the theory short but it's it's far from
conclusive it what does the story come
with louis farrakhan where it's hey are
we good I want to make sure I'm good
with the brother or Muslim but you know
the Muslim you know that that
conversation was that puffy and then
what does that take yeah so that takes
place the night prior to Biggie's murder
and the Petersen there at the Soul Train
Awards there Puffy's entourage his
bad-boy entourage gets into a little bit
of a confrontation with members of the
Nation
Islam and that's when did he supposedly
says over to Farrakhan hey we're cool
right I mean do we need do we need this
and they call the incident got it
but is there anything connected with
that here or not at all
there's nothing connected other than
he's Muslim not fruit of Islam but
Muslim and there's a conflict the night
before got it so it's completely
separate completely separate got it
completely separate but for him it's a
loose connection yes sure
so now what what role does rafael Ray
Perez play so Perez is most notable he's
kind of the face of what became known as
the rampart scandal in Los Angeles he
was another dirty cop who was going to
our evidence checking out cocaine under
an alias name and then going out and
selling and using the cocaine for his
own profit
he becomes discovered during that
internal investigation and then he
ultimately makes a deal with the
district attorney's office in Los
Angeles and starts to name all these
other people that he claims were dirty
cops these are a lot of dirty cops at
that time is a list of the long list or
not really the whole rampart scandal
ultimately turned out to be like three
guys okay include you know he's putting
his show he's the main one so he was
just throwing all kinds of dirt in every
direction trying to get himself out of
trouble he's making a lot of false
allegations against a lot of innocent
cops but the rampart scandal legend kind
of just took on a life of its own and
it's perceived as something much bigger
than it actually was these guys used to
work together and so there was some
there was some suspicion that he was
also involved in the bank robbery but
that had that had been ultimately
refuted so now you have this you read
this you do the investigation 97 binders
you're going through it this is what
Russell Poulos theory is next where do
you go next so he's developed his theory
he's presenting it to the department
they're like okay this is
circumstantially interesting but it's
far from being conclusive let's not
start making allegations let's not start
making you know
adding to the newspaper fodder with this
theory he gets frustrated and walks away
from the job basically just quits the
job a year prior to qualifying for his
retirement and he goes out and writes a
book and so you've got you know a year
and a half worth of investigative
material in these books the case of
Biggie Smalls is assigned to another
investigator Tupac's case is still being
worked out in Las Vegas but he goes and
writes a book called labyrinth and that
leads to based on the book a lawsuit is
waged against the LAPD this is the four
hundred million dollar loss this is the
four hundred million dollar lawsuit
that's waged against the LAPD based on
the allegations in the book that he that
he helps to write an attorney gets ahold
of Biggie's mom and says listen I've
read this book by the sex detective in
Los Angeles he's got all this incredible
information about how cops were involved
and they're covering it up let's sue the
department get to the bottom of this so
that's what takes place the civil
lawsuit goes in and out of court federal
court state court dismissed refiled and
ultimately in 2006 the LAPD says listen
let's put a full-court press on this get
a bunch of people involved and that's
how I get involved and we start to take
a take a fresh look at everything
involving the case but of course now
it's nine years later nine years later
so no now you're on the 400 million
dollar lawsuit just a question for you
when when the when the City of LA gets a
lawsuit that big are they worried
because they don't have the funds to go
lawyer up and protect themselves is that
where they're first brain ghost it was
like man we cannot afford that kind of a
lawsuit it's a it's a combination yes of
course it's that you know nobody wants
to you know you never know what is gonna
happen in a civil case you know you just
juries are very fickle and you can't
afford to lose that kind of money four
hundred million dollars is no small
change so they say listen we're
confident based on all the investigative
effort that has taken place in that nine
year period because it wasn't just him
investigators teams of investigators had
looked into all of his claims and the
LAPD was very confident that should this
go to court they can successfully defend
it and get out from under that lawsuit
but in order to do that they had to
resurrect the case and have us take a
new look at it and see if we've missed
anything so so why did they go from him
to use that because he had the heart
attack and he died no he died years
later after I had already after we'd
already been involved he died long after
the loss yesterday they just died a few
years ago who was he about to have a
meeting with that he was and then
something happened where he'd had a
heart attack right before that he was
over at the homicide unit of the LA
County Sheriff's in the LA County
Sheriff's was at that time in charge of
the investigation of Suge Knight when he
ran over and killed this guy Terry
Carter it's a completely unrelated event
but the LA County Sheriff's Department
is pursuing him as a I was a murder
suspect for running this guy over and
Russell Poole says hey I've got this
idea let's make sure
let's cut chick night a deal on this
murder in order to get him to cooperate
about the things he knows regarding
these two murders during that meeting
the investigators kind of looking at him
cross-eyed all these years had gone by
he comes out of the woodwork he's been
suffering from a whole bunch of you know
personal problems and he basically just
collapsed and dies right there at the
table
it's purely a conspiracy when people try
to connect their with any other events
oh yeah no kid it's just now here's
another nut but he died from a heart
attack died from a heart attack got tons
of stress for years yeah I mean makes
sense this is it's the world filled with
stress so so you you explained this
situation perfectly well now what do you
do next so as we get involved you know
we're gonna treat all these theories as
if they're true and then through a
process of elimination come up to the
one that we can't disprove and that's
the most viable theory and then we're
gonna try to corroborate that so as
we're looking into this we know about
all the conflict that's taking place
between these crews between bad boy and
death row and POC and big and of course
the gangs so we ultimately want to
corner this guy
because we knew that he was a he's a
known gang member from Compton we know
he was in Las Vegas at the time of Tupac
shooting and we know that he was at the
Petersen Auto Museum the night the
biggie was killed so he's a person of
extreme interest up to this point in
time he'd been interviewed and says he
doesn't really know anything and you
know kind of gives a you know throws a
bunch of curveballs at us so we know
that he's not going to sit down and just
be transparent and open with us after
all these years we develop a an airtight
drug case against him because you know
we're aware of the fact he's got a known
history of dealing drugs and
particularly to this guy in New York and
we put an ironclad case against him
approach him and say here's the deal KPD
we have questions about these murders if
you don't cooperate you're going to
prison for the rest of your life and so
are several members of your family who
are caught up in your drug organization
he confesses to his involvement in the
murder of Tupac Shakur in Las Vegas in
1996 he tells us that his nephew Orlando
Anderson was in the same car with him
which was the white Cadillac and they
had gotten into the fight obviously
between Tupac and Orlando and now
they're going to go and retaliate at the
club where they know that Tupac and Suge
are gonna be and they go over to the
club in hunt of and to hunt down Tupac
and prior to that they meet with this
guy in Las Vegas who happens to be
biggie smalls Godfather he's a close
friend of puffy he's out in Las Vegas
he's aware of all this conflict going on
he's aware of the shooting of Tupac and
so he gives him a gun in Las Vegas and
then they set out along with another guy
named Cory Edwards and five or six other
members of the south side Crips and they
go on the hunt for Tupac in and Suge
Knight ultimately they run into him on
the strip just off the strip actually
and at the intersection of Flamingo and
Koval the Cadillac pulls up he gives him
the gun he leans out and shoots and
ultimately kills Tupac Shakur and in the
car he's sitting in the front passenger
Terrance Brown T Brown it's a de jure
driver he had
think it's mother-in-law rented the car
in the Cadillac and apparently key feed
every time he would go out he would
always rent a car and then in the back
is Orlando right behind the behind
Phoebe and then DeAndre sitting on this
side he first gives the gun to DeAndre
because the cars on this side the andra
says no mm-hmm then he Orlando says give
it to me he turns around and he shoots
get some so that's pretty much the event
that takes place and a lot of it was the
attention because the girls were
hollering hey to power cage again yeah
they figured out there then they made a
u-turn to go get him right that's right
yep so where do we go from here so now
he looks like he looks like a Cuba
Gooding jr. from American Gangster not
Frank Lucas but the guy that Frank Lucas
was going up against who was making blue
magic and spicing it up and selling it
for cheaper price anyway so just an
interesting guy he's a known most it was
a well-known established drug dealer in
Harlem for years I was getting a you
know a grip of dope from ki fede out
here on the east on the west coast
anyways he died a few years ago of
cancer natural causes but he was a
co-conspirator in this murder associated
with these guys and then of course these
are your two primary suspects he
provides the gun in the direction and he
follows it and does the shooting so now
we have a confessing co-conspirator in
the murder which is huge for us
investigative Li you know we now we've
got testimonial evidence to support this
this theory and he tells us things that
he could not have known had he not been
actually at the scene at the time of the
murder
so we we corroborate what he says and it
validate it so now we have for all
intent and purposes solve this murder so
now we're still got our other objective
which is to figure out what happened to
biggie
so we take the same investigative
approach and we know that Suge has got a
girlfriend
we've given her an alias of Theresa
Swann and that she's complicit in a
whole bunch of kind of white-collar
crimes fraud forgery and that type of
things has she ever done time with gone
cops or no she's been to jail
so she had a has a record she has her
backup and a lot she she's got a history
she was his bad girl you know shook out
a lot of women in his life this happened
to be the one that that he could count
on to do something that the other girls
may not be willing to do so we we
basically find out that she's involved
in a bunch of fraud related to auto
automobile were purchasing we do the
same thing with her that we did to him
we approach her and tell her listen
we've got a case against you
we're not only gonna send you to jail
that we're gonna have your young
children put into you know put into
foster care and you know your world is
gonna take a big 180 if you don't tell
us what you know she ultimately breaks
down confesses that after the murder of
Tupac Shakur shug's at the county jail
she goes and meets with him Suge says
listen I want biggie killed I want you
to go ahead and get ahold of my boy
cappucci from the neighborhood he knows
poochie's a known shooter and he agrees
to pay her twenty five thousand dollars
half of what she gives to Poochie and
they conspired to do the murder so on
the night of Biggie Smalls murder at the
Petersen Auto Museum she goes to the to
the party he lies in wait outside in a
dark-colored Impala that Suge Knight had
purchased for him and as Biggie Smalls
and the entourage are leaving he just
simply pulls up alongside starts to
shoot it's it's the big man who dies on
the way to the hospital so this was
validated by Theresa Swann LEM you know
whatever name you gave her was validated
by her correct okay and and based on and
under in another interview with Reggie
right he always saw them but away from
everybody talking it was almost like a
it wasn't a public relationship it was
more like a private relationship they
had right right when you look back at
the activities around death-row and
specifically Suge Knight in his
entourage of gang members they were
always out front and center
you know they that was the image that
Suge Knight wanted for his record
company Reggie right explained to us but
the relationship with Poochie was
something completely different
poochy would stay in the cut poochy and
sugar would always go off on their own
to have private conversations we knew he
was already wanted for at least one
murder and so he was the kind of guy
that you would go to if you needed
something like that done is it fair to
say that on this list of all these faces
the toughest guys on this list he would
be one of them these are your killers
okay right here got it right these are
your CEOs and you know in a shot-caller
God but these guys you know at the at
the top of the food chain and because
this whole thing never got dealt with
responsibly these two guys suffer the
consequences got it so what what happens
next so now you know poochie's did you
guys make a letter that hey he testified
and he's already told us right before he
died and even on the letter you put the
date of the letter was April 1st 1998
meaning April Fool's
yeah I think we were just trying to be a
little bit too clever but ultimately it
worked she reads the letter that's a
ruse it's a fictitious confession letter
that was signed by him and given to an
attorney before he was he was shot and
killed in 2002 on a motorcycle driving
up the street most of these guys have
all you know expired so we show her the
letter she says Wow that's exactly what
happened we tell her well why don't you
tell us what happened in your words she
explains her solicitation was Suge
Knight how he had paid her and how he
had told her to get a hold of him and
commit the murders so we corroborated
her statements and now for all intensive
effectively have solved both these
murders because we have corroborated Co
confessing co-conspirators that are
confessing so that's where we go to the
department and we say listen we've got
all the goods or the department then has
their attorneys reach out to Voletta
Wallace in the estate and say listen
we've got new information in the case it
undermines INRI future civil case you
can continue to pursue that and spend
money but this is where we're going with
it
the letter Wallace an attorney at the
hearing that they decide that they're
going to reach
their lawsuit it's dismissed the whole
time 400 million whole K ever happened
whole case goes away you've said that
you believe behind all of this is puffy
you've said this yourself with a million
dollars where there was a million
dollars where there wasn't half a
million dollars tell us a little bit
about that what I believe happened with
with puffy was that again I don't think
he wanted this conflict to get worse
than it already was and if he could
figure out a way to quell that he would
in fact we have a statement saying that
puffy had reached out to the members of
the Nation of Islam to approach Suge
Knight and say hey let's have a peace
treaty let's squash this thing but
should wanted nothing to do with it so
he was trying to get out from under this
imposing threat
knowing that Suge held him responsible
for the murder of his friend and
whenever he would come to LA he knew
that Suge Knight was trying to hunt him
down we have a reported incident an
investigation where Suge Knight had
accosted one of his associates at a
Christmas party in Los Angeles and they
beat the living [ __ ] out of this guy he
almost lost his eye in an attempt for
these guys to gain knowledge about where
he lived in Los Angeles so he
undoubtedly becomes aware of the fact
that these guys are actively hunting me
down they're kidnapping assaulting
people
my life's definitely in harm's way and
so I think that out of that desperation
and fear he turned to the streets and
said can you guys kind of handle this
for me because he knew that if you're
gonna deal with these gang members then
the best thing to do is get their
natural enemies - you know - to do the
work for you and is that the million
dollars million dollars was on the
according to ki fede he says there is a
kind of a loose conversations at
Greenblatt Sept on Sunset in which puffy
allegedly tells ki fede listen I mean
whatever it Nate whatever it takes to
get these guys off my back I need you to
take care of them he says we wanted a
million dollars Diddy's like whatever
but again I have to couch that with
the understanding that he was in fear
for his life now I fully get that yeah I
fully get that so but the million
dollars is from him well you don't know
really if it's a million dollars or it's
a half a million dollars I just think
it's just boastful talking okay no it's
like I saw if I see a really nice car
that I like to purchase from you and I
just man I'll give you a million dollars
for that yeah it's just that kind of
like loose so the part where we're gives
him the gun he says listen that right
now is the time to do it every once in
town go to 662 here's a gun that I have
he leaves a tune with the car right he
gives him the gun and then afterwards
when they talk on a call he says was
that us and they're on the call together
listening and zip says yes that was us
chief he says yes that was yes that was
a TV says that was us and then then he
says we'll take your zip says we'll take
care of the money six weeks later he's
not getting the money and you know he's
finding out maybe he didn't get paid and
then afterwards he meets with an
associate up he did he's saying puffy
saying yeah we did pay but they wrapped
it and then when they met is that all
been verified that maybe he did keep the
money or they did not pay we don't have
anything to validate other than his
claim got it he's claiming that he had
people that were closely associated with
Eric that was zip
they told him hey puffy paid a half a
million dollars and zip kept the money
so that's his claim we do know that
these two people do exist and that they
were associated with him but those
people have never verified that so that
that unpaid debt is it was definitely
never collected so why were you removed
from the case in 2009 or to you know a
year before your retirement why did they
I mean obviously the show is called
unsolved right on the Netflix why was it
like listen you're gonna let it too deep
with this stop what you're doing we're
gonna we're gonna remove you and go a
different direction
for the LAPD once we bring them the
confession of key fede their attitude is
like okay well that's Las Vegas case
pass all the information you have on
Tupac's murder to
Las Vegas let them deal with ki fede let
them follow up in in and handle their
own murder case with Biggie's case now
the LAPD is out from under this massive
lawsuit they're breathing a sigh of
relief
they've just spent millions of dollars
conducting this investigation with
wiretaps and narcotics buys and all of
this you know is a large operation and
at that point in time they realize
prosecute prosecution wise it's going to
be very very difficult to take the
remaining co-conspirators which at that
time really consisted of ki fede Eric
Martin and Diddy and prosecute these
guys based on the sole testimony of a
convicted drug dealing gang member so
they realize that it's going to be very
very tough to prosecute these people
we've spent enough time and energy on
this Gregg you're gonna get reassigned
back to cold case homicides everybody
else go back to your respective agencies
and they just that's it right yeah but
is that nothing bigger than that it
wasn't like hey let's try to find out
more your this is gonna get us in
trouble we don't want to get more
negativity behind it or maybe even some
cops internally or trying to protect
some people that are living any of those
things could be possibilities or no not
for me you know not at all I think it's
just simply they were kind of
indifferent about it like hey Voletta
Wallace sued us we spent a lot of money
trying to defend this lawsuit we've
spent a little whole lot of money trying
to pursue the truth we found that and
now we're just gonna let sleeping dogs
lie
because we can't prosecute the case you
know for all intents is it's not
practical with with with Biggie's murder
and so you know you've got an
ex-girlfriend who's known to commit
perjury and she's going to take the
stand and be the sole witness against
Suge Knight saying that he because this
guy is dead remember and so now you've
got this you know relationship between
the two and she's the only person you
can put on the stand you know pointing
the finger at him it's just not gonna
work out in court and same thing with
Tupac's murder you know these guys just
don't have any credibility and so far as
getting on the stand and testifying
because of their back
groans and their previous you know
convictions and statuses gang members
and in established perjurers it's just
complicated and so even do you have this
much evidence it's still complicated I
mean what that what that what that then
tells a person watching how is how are
they protected at this point that you
know this happened you're not talking
about a small brand this guy was growing
at a level that was pretty wild and
you're not talking about I'm not even
talking here I'm specifically staying
here with the talent they're the ones
this making the money they're the ones
creating the opportunity but they're the
ones that are doing the talent don't
isn't there a reason to want to go
really find that the truth for not only
fans families people involved businesses
involved with them it's in their reason
to even go deeper with that well there
you know for us there's a saying in in
investigative circles it's not what you
know it's what you can prove and knowing
what happened is one thing but then
going to court and successfully
prosecuting people to bring them justice
that's a different thing it's it's a
different it's a different it's just a
different you know ball to juggle and so
we know what happened conclusively with
all confidence and so that is the reason
why I speak about the case and why I
wrote the book about the case is because
I believe the public should at least be
informed as to what took place in the
investigation what evidence we developed
and how this all fits together but as
far as prosecuting people and getting
judicial justice in these cases it's
never gonna happen
that's done yeah the best thing we could
have done you know rest in peace Afeni
Shakur the best thing we could have done
was at least let the family and their
friends know what happened and many of
those people have given us their
feedback saying we've always known that
was the truth the family and friends
have told you oh absolutely not to be
true yeah many of them when I spoke with
with his aunt Gloria and I told her
about the book and explained what was in
it she said that's very interesting
thank you for all your time and effort
that we always knew that so and of
course we know that Afeni Shakur had
sued Orlando Anderson
after the shooting claiming that he was
the the shooter how much after almost
you know within a year because he was
going on at parties talking about I'm
the one that killed Tupac yeah Keef he
said why don't you stop talking exactly
loud yeah he was he was boasting about
it in the neighborhood so it was not a
well-kept secret the people in the
neighborhood in their inner circle they
all knew that he was responsible for it
but again it's very difficult to then
get those people with any credibility up
on the witness stand and prosecute
successfully what are the chances of
another thing like do you think we're at
a point right now due to again social
media where to start another East Coast
West Coast type of stuffs pretty much
mathematically impossible to do it today
I do believe it is just because of
technology sure you know back when Tupac
was shot in Las Vegas there was no
traffic cameras even the video that we
see during the fight between these two
at the MGM it's so grainy you can barely
even make out images so technology's
come so far you'd have cell phone videos
traffic cameras all types of things that
we could have utilized more effectively
had we had that technology twenty years
and it would have been easier to and
faster to figure out who it was yeah if
you had the technology we have today I
believe so so how about Keef he did the
fact that he's going around talking and
he's you know saying a lot of different
things right now in many different
interviews can he get himself in trouble
with Las Vegas PD going after him
what are you saying absolutely so his
initial confession to us was done under
what's known as a proffer session it's a
it's an agreement between his attorney
him and his attorney and the prosecution
in this case the US Attorney's Office
where he can disclose everything he
knows about a crime answer all of our
questions truthfully but we can't use
his own self incriminating criminais
ting statements against him
it's called kind of queen for a day you
cannot use your own self incriminating
statements against yourself you can't
use it against the individual correct
now that doesn't mean that he has
immunity that just simply means he's he
can't use his own testimony against him
if other evidence or another people you
so if a person says I did kill that
person you can't use that against a
person under the you
conditions of this agreement this
property make conditions of disagreement
right not just the average person of
course you know this agreement that he's
made it's a particular agreement having
to do with the fact that a bunch of
narcotics yeah that makes sense
and then and then a night to follow up
which I'm sorry to interrupt but the
statements that he's made publicly after
that the ones that are not under a
proper agreement he's gone on BET's gone
on Vlad TV he's gone on all types of
different platforms and tells the story
about his involvement the involvement of
his nephew this this story as I've
explained it to you he's confessed to it
multiple times now and we're all sitting
here kind of dumbfounded why Las Vegas
hasn't reeled him in and in dealt with
him you're when you say we who is we you
and everybody that's involved in this
case yeah okay fan got it
sure investigators got advocates for you
know for these gentlemen so is that an
indirect way of hinting to him that stop
talking and just kind of go live your
life and stop talking about the stories
it's only gonna get one person in
trouble and it's him no I'm talking
about you know go out there and you know
because again I think that the story
that he's revealing is for Alton you
know he put some little twists on it but
you know he's ultimately explaining what
happened I believe that Las Vegas PD and
the LAPD based on the evidence that we
have currently should clear the cases in
set history right now these men their
cases are not unsolved they're
unprosecuted unprosecuted not unsolved
unprosecuted how big of a difference is
the personality between them two I mean
I know they grew up in the same place
how big of a difference in personality
did they have quite quite different in
person they they can both be somewhat
charming you know sitting down and
talking to ki fede he was cordial and
respectful and and truthful but at the
there's this whole other side to him as
there is to him what makes these guys
dangerous is not who they are it's who
they know it's the guys that they can
influence to go out and commit the
crimes and do the shootings so you know
these guys as shot-callers or dangerous
by the nature of who they feel
themselves yeah they called a shot
somebody's got to go handle it right
last think your F gary Gray what
involvement does he have with this whole
thank you so F gary Gray was producing a
show called Straight Outta Compton
basically the feature film showing the
development and life of NWA he was going
to have a character within this feature
film of Suge Knight Suge Knight felt
that he owes him money for using his
image and so he began to show up at the
set in Compton when they were shooting
the feature and kind of threatening
people around F gary Gray so F gary Gray
and other people involved in the
production they get a hold of a guy
named Terry Carter they know Terry
Carter he's one of those guys from the
neighborhood everybody respects he's a
guy that can go in and kind of mitigate
a situation and so he goes and tries to
meet with Suge Knight down at a
hamburger stand not too far from the set
and Suge Knight and another individual
that came from the set a guy named clay
Slone get into a fight clay is hitting
showed through the window of his truck
Suge backs up and runs over clay and
almost kills him and then he pulls
forward and runs over Terry Carter and
kills him so you can pull this video up
it's it's a very graphic video of him it
is run over and killed ultimately he
gets prosecuted for that vehicular
manslaughter and receives a 28 year
sentence what's he's currently serving
and for all intent and purpose that's a
that's a life sentence that's a life
sentence for someone like him have you
ever had to sit down with him
face-to-face or no I've conducted tons
of surveillance with him listen to phone
calls with him and you know obviously
seen all of his interviews but I've
never actually sat down face to face
with sugar when you do to surveillance
as he sounded like a pretty firm guy
meaning if he wants something to be done
to people he's a tremendous manipulator
okay tremendous manipulator nobody knows
that better than Reggie right junior
who's out there vocally talking about
his history with death row his
involvement with Suge Knight and you
know he's uh you know he's got a really
interesting story to tell also so let me
ask a question a Greg at this point
everybody here can anyone
be litigated today that hasn't yet been
not really the only the only
possibilities I see is that these guys
created work environments that led to
their murders and so there is a you know
there is a civil situation where when
you create such a hostile environment
within the workplace and then somebody
suffers harm because of it that that's
that's an actionable thing of course it
would have to take his mother to kind of
perceive that and see things that way
but it's still a long shot not like it's
a lot if they if they long shot if they
couldn't do anything who's mother with
the four hundred million and after all
this it's probably going to be a long
shot to do that it really is their
keeping in mind that also that you know
in in a criminal court you're trying to
prove something beyond a shadow of a
doubt in civil court the burden of proof
is that much lower and it's just more of
a preponderance of the evidence so
what's to come next with you Greg with
this story is this story pretty much
done for you I mean obviously it turn
into the book turn into a documentary
turned into a series I know yet a couple
scenes as the bartender in the Netflix
area what's to come next with this story
anything to expect not really you know
like I said the majority of these guys
have all met their demise and there's
not much more to say about it we've got
the bottom of it and I think we can
conclusively and definitive if we say
this is what happened to these two
individuals and this is the historical
factual case well I can tell you one
thing I was in high school when this
happened and I was a dying I mean I'm a
die hard to park fan at the time as a
kid we were listening to him I got him
into painting and I've been on a flight
with him before I almost sold him an
insurance policy but the insurance
carriers will never approve I had a
meeting with him one time through one of
my associates at the Beverly Hills
Hilton and I said I can't sell this guy
nations policy was gonna ensure sugar
yeah you know it's a very interesting
story and you know I know obviously a
lot of time was put into it to
investigate this so thank you for your
service to do that and get to the bottom
of it and tell the story and you know
turn it into a book in a movie now and
outside of that you know if you haven't
watched the series on Netflix called
unsolved if you haven't watched it one
go watch it it's ten I think it's ten
episodes an episode limited series yeah
ten episode limited series and then on
top of that if you haven't watched a
documentary or the book we're gonna put
the links to both of them below as well
for you to go out there and check them
out and outside of that you got any
comments questions comment below but
Greg we appreciate your coming out man
this was great yeah this vigil was a
very different approach absolutely yeah
this is I think this is the most
effective way to tell the story it's a
convoluted and complicated story but at
least this this helps to put faces to
names and put it together I agree this
is a complete different way of looking
at it absolutely thanks for coming out
absolutely hope you enjoyed the
interview with Greg gating especially
with the pictures that we put up there
and bother we would love to hear your
thoughts about this interview and what
questions comes up you can either
comment below or tweet me directly at
Patrick Bay David I got two other
interviews I want you to watch one of
them is very deep wit freeway Rick Ross
I think the last 30 minutes of it if you
watch the entire interview go to the
last 30 minutes of it it may be one of
the most insightful interviews we had
about how to change the perception and
mindset of somebody that's raised in
that community and the other one is
vanilla ice believe it or not I said
we've analyzed there was a conversation
of Suge Knight putting vandalised over a
balcony to toss him down and he kind of
want you know who took some of his
rights and I asked him the question of
who I thought who he thinks that took
out Tupac you should hear his answer
very unique way he responds to the
question I asked about who he thinks
killed Tupac
either way freeway Rick Ross on this
side winner lies on this side
you
[Music]